I ordered the Swedish candy when I was 36 weeks pregnant
and it just came like a week ago.
I forgot we even ordered it.
So let's taste test it together.
A lot of this is just red candy.
I already know these are gonna be good.
How do you know?
I just know.
Cause they remind you of the German version?
Yeah. Okay,
what are we trying first?
Those. These ones.
Okay, this is what we're gonna try first.
We're gonna rate them. Thank you.
Good, but underwhelming.
Say six out of 10.
Seven. Six.
Six and a half.
Try these next.
These. I've actually had them before when we went to New York.
I got Swedish candy
and I really like them.
Should I be expecting with this?
It's, like, soft.
Mm hmm.
These are 9.2 for me.
4. Not like them.
We have very different taste buds.
We're trying these next.
We have this White Center.
We have a lady in the trap moment.
Still chewing the other candy,
are you? Actually,
I'm really underwhelmed,
but maybe I'm spoiled by the German candy.
I feel like German candy is superior to all the candies.
Maybe cause I'm German,
but that's just my opinion.
Starts out as a 3.
Mmm.
Starts off as a 4 cause you're like, mmm,
different textures.
And then it gets grainy and it turns into 3.
Very interesting.
What do we do next?
The one that I like.
This one. Sorry.
The green ones.
We're Gonna try these green ones next.
Mediocre.
Taste like green apple,
so that's a plus five.
I feel my cavities already.
Right now, these ones are next.
Remind me if this German candy called Freddy Fakka.
They're Lucky's favorite candy,
so let's see whether these compare to them at all,
because they look kind of similar.
I wonder whether the two colors have two different flavors.
Mmm. They are so soft and chewy.
Mmm. An eight
7 one. These I've heard are really sour.
Yeah. Let's try,
let's try, let's try.
I think I need, like,
something sour to break up all the sweetness.
We have a yellow and red side.
Let's try the red first.
To me, they're not that sour.
The yellow side is really good.
I think it's lemon.
This is our last flavor.
She's distracting me.
I'm sorry.
This is our last one.
This is very similar to the other red one.
I mean,
I'll be honest,
I'm very underwhelmed.
Me, too. These stole the show.
These ones were my favorite.
But what's your overall rating for this candy?
Like, would you repurchase?
I wouldn't. Definitely would not repurchase.
Those are a little taste test.